okay this is just like your eyes sorry
God
we were just quoting that before doesn't
look goes kick your balls into outer
space it's nothing to do with that I'm
sorry my fault
essentially think about staring off this
review that wait no reason it's correct
okay then this is still Jake suit
nonetheless um okay so if Finny's warn
Jake before is such a weird thing to say
but and he starts off wearing him in
this too and he really abuses Jake in
the suit
you know if for fun it takes us how
would you like if I was in your suit and
you know and I was inside the anyhow he
said bring it on so he does it and plays
not able to hurt him very well so first
he has to read a boring book terrarium
and then Flame Princess is having a kid
together with her nice yet very
judgemental family great designs and all
of them oh yeah yeah the house of design
anything with that flame universe is
designed great yeah I love it
and it's I'm just I look for it every
time it's like ooh Flame Princess has a
thing at blank or we're gonna beat blank
it's like yes let's go let's go cuz
they're always they just always look
wonderful
um so Jake still in the body forces him
to take the tablecloth strip down naked
except his underpants to the baby dance
and totally humiliate him
but Flame Princess finds out so it's
okay and then wants to push it further
so he goes to rainicorns house and I'm
assuming she said the son was still
living at home correct yes what that was
TV TV yeah and he says why don't you
throw him in a volcano so that's what
Jake's gonna do
Finn is just nuts and is totally going
for it and like it's starting to burn
his brain emotes and finally Jake pulls
out says okay I can't do that to you but
then Finn gives inside to Jake they go
inside the volcano they're all bandaged
up in those fucking crazy clowns come
again which is like the perfect ending
I mean just like what a great return of
those characters cuz nobody can forget
those characters every once a while like
somebody comes home like who's that it
was but it's like nobody can forget
those clowns they were so terrifying so
when they come back it's just so great
merchants therapy so um I can't think of
a ton to talk about this one it's fun
it's I mean it's definitely uh enjoyable
um it was one of the few times where I'm
just like you know Jake Jesus see you
know your beads so hearts but then like
vanda's being so harsh on himself near
the end like yeah burn my brain burn my
brain and then and even in the opening
Finn is being so mean oh they're just
you know bruises are the hickeys of the
universe from the universe or something
and it's like these two are just nuts
and honestly when he was started
applying the volcano I was just like
it's a lot of a few times more for a
kids show I'm like a little bit
comfortable by this cuz you see people
that do like the jackass stuff you know
like but aren't on jackass and they're
like no no this is gonna give us famous
Durer and like they've really hurt
themselves and all there is I'm just
like and that makes awesome YouTube
videos don't from I wanna see a bunch of
like idiots trying to do volcano stuff
because they get what they deserve okay
no cuz I saw my car yeah you go ahead
and do that I and we'll see what happens
idiot yeah population control Jack say
thank you very much
I I love them more on the fence about
that but I don't know oh but it but it
doesn't matter cuz that's not that's not
the focus that's not what it amounts to
I mean why see Jake pulls out and then
Finn acts like a dumbass and they get
hurt so I'm like it's it seemed okay it
seemed fine at a funny ending um yeah I
can't it's uh it was funny I I guess I
can't think of too much else to say
about it a while ago we talked about the
Jake the dog episode and I said you know
Jake was being in the house yeah and
being selfish not sorry in this episode
Finn's being a complete ass
like in the beginning he's you know
literally abusing Jake and not taking
into account any of the pain that Jake
is feeling because he's not feeling it
it's not there
good BMO throwing hot coffee on me
continue to hit me I mean you know and I
felt fin was just being a complete ass
in the beginning because yeah not taking
into account Jake
but when Jacobson is trying to do it
Jake's ad D kicks in and he's not able
to do anything effectively I'm gonna
read you a book and he answer falling
asleep before he gets anywhere oh I'm
gonna make you food it's delicious here
look mmm and instead of like taking the
time to take bite after bite is a
holiday again yeah he has no patience
for anything so it's kind of like he's
screwing himself over trying to screw
over Finn yeah you know and instead of
you know when Flame Princess comes out
and finds out and she's like oh that's
cool
good luck and Jake's just like oh wait a
minute I'm sorry I'd go back and still
do more I know what so what if she knows
the other people don't know this what's
going on here it I mean it's I don't
just say it is nice though at the end
it's like he does get his comeuppance Oh
Finn does yeah so like I said I feel
it's still sorry it like it evened out
okay but I just actually felt bad for
Jake this episode he wanted Finn to
finally feel what it's like to be you
know on the outside you know and he just
couldn't do it
like well I like I like how they showed
him cuz I was like well how's it going
to control oh yeah and the way sir
worked through all the little creeks and
veins and stuff - good I thought that
was very funny that was really cool and
the fact that you can't control him as
well because if he goes anymore I can
probably kill him
yeah sure what was the other thing I was
gonna say Daniel sorry no that's okay
you don't know there was one thing I was
sort of watching it I don't even know if
it's like a criticism or what that's
just interesting cuz there's always I
mean I think a lot of people have seen a
family where it's like there's a big
family then there's
usually like a late bloomer or somebody
that doesn't leave the house or needs
longer to get something going sometimes
they get used to it and don't want to
leave and they become lazy and stuff
sometimes or late bloomers and stuff um
and that's obviously they're kind of
mocking that with the kid that stays at
home but it's funny because I'm also
thinking myself what I've been reading
what I've been observing with so many
people now because of college cause so
much and because the job market though
apparently better is still really tough
uh so many kids are leaving home much
later than me no no magic on top of that
uh truth be told in the state - they
said they're just getting along with
their parents better you know the best
barbecue I don't like you breathe you
can see the face you're leaving at 18
right but but no but what I was getting
to with that is that we're used to
always be the stereotype love your
living at home you're a loser you're
lazy or whatever something's wrong with
you it's like now it's it's not
necessarily the norm but it's not like
you know unheard of anymore because of
the way things are right now because the
market is so tough because things are so
expensive so it's just an interesting
observation because it's like I saw that
I kind of laugh and I said wait is that
totally true anymore like there
definitely are people there just like I
said don't want to go responsibility and
are lazy and will take advantage of
their parents but there's definitely a
lot of people that you know just it's
very tough to get you know out there and
and to get things going I'm gonna be
terrible a terrible person right now
when I saw TV city like there he is the
fat one out of all the kids he's the fat
one
he had a scruff he was on the computer
with that headset that well that's my
whole player yeah - and I'm sorry I saw
that and I'm like yep that's one of
those and you know what I've got a
scruff going right now
I've got a gun I'm not no skinny guy or
anything like that but that's first
thing about to my head was all the
typical kid living in the you know
parents basements oh yeah and like I
said I I think they're emphasizing like
he was sort of the lazy one I just
wanted to play video games and that go
get a job and stuff um but yeah like I
said it's just fine that it's like if
they say home house just like the
immediate association because he's like
well all the others lent him he stayed
you know and but it's like yeah it's not
quite it used to be just the immediate
stereotype but now it's like it's a bit
tougher you know it's mix of it you know
no no no yeah okay I'm a janitor I've
said that a billion times what you think
I wanted to be like Oh suck it I'll tell
you right now I was a janitor for
several years um I was I want you going
with no one's there nobody's there he'll
deal with anybody when it's awesome and
I will work outside stuff well you know
when I got back you know and in other
projects and stuff you know get things
going and I just or you know like this
I'm you can let you do the podcast and
we're feeling stuff like that and it's I
loved being a janitor I had no shame in
it but ya know it's just an interesting
observation that it's like hey I don't
know it's it doesn't seem like it's as
obvious anymore though I still believe
those people definitely exist you know
the ones they're like just not even
trying or or are trying a million things
but not like focusing on one thing you
know you right now yeah it's kind of all
over the place and yeah but I'm a genius
oh it worked no no I can't argue at all
no honestly it's no cuz I've seen this
word people like either they do nothing
or
they have a million things they want to
do which is fine it's good to have a lot
of things but you gotta find one to put
them up your most time in and what seems
the most practical and logical and say
you know there is still a business
aspect a make a living at it you know I
mean and I was an illustrator before
doing this I love being an illustrator
I'd love to keep doing it but I can't
this takes up too much time you know so
you have to discriminate again this
seems the most logical to go is you're
talking about discrimination oh this I
wanna partake in any of this
discrimination
yes about Oh what happened we don't
believe in magic